[Music]
uh
you know
[Music]
crazy
[Music]
thank you
thank you
please
thank you
thank you
yes
oh
ah
[Music]
like
oh my goodness
oh
um
oh
[Music]
oh okay
[Music]
thank you
she's
peace
oh
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
together
here
[Music]
[Music]
right
there was a failure
yes
your best
[Music]
nice
i can work more fun
lock my feet
this
thank you
yes
uh
you think
yes
um
yes
soldiers
users
thank you
uh yeah
yes
do we
yes yes
is
yes
ladies and gentlemen the president of
the united states accompanied by the
vice president of the united states
[Applause]
sometimes
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
all righty then
good afternoon everyone good afternoon
let me start by saying to all of the
leaders here
thank you thank you
to the members of our united states
congress
on both sides of the aisle who helped
pass
the covet 19 hate crimes act
thank you
and a special thanks to senator maisie
hirono
for leading this incredible effort and i
know you did not do it alone
and there are many more i could name a
couple of whom i will
among them senator tammy duckworth
senator richard blumenthal
senator jerry moran
[Applause]
congresswoman judy chu
congressman don beyer
and congressman fred upton
of you history will remember this day
and this moment when our nation took
action to combat hate
thank you all around this time last year
when i was in the senate senator hirono
and senator duckworth and i
introduced a resolution in the united
states senate
condemning the rise of anti-aging
sentiment in our country
at that time more than one thousand one
hundred
anti-asian hate incidents have been
reported
since the start of the pandemic today
that number is more than six thousand
six hundred
and i'm talking about incidents where
businesses
are being vandalized in our biggest
cities and in our smallest towns
i'm talking about a 61 year old man
getting kicked in the head
two elderly women being stabbed while
waiting for the bus
eight people in atlanta getting shot on
a tuesday night
this violence it did not come from
nowhere
and none of it is new in my life
my lived experience i have seen how hate
can pervade our communities i have
served
in the justice system in the legislative
branch
and in the executive branch i have seen
how hate can impede our progress
and i have seen how people
uniting against hate can strengthen
our country those here today
are united this bill brings
us one step closer to stopping hate
not only for asian americans but for all
americans
it will expedite the justice
department's review of hate crimes
every type of hate crime it will
designate
an official at the department to oversee
the effort
and it will expand efforts to make the
reporting of hate crimes
more accessible at the local and state
levels
but after the president signs this bill
today
our work will not be done here is the
truth
racism exists in america
xenophobia exists in america
anti-semitism islamophobia homophobia
transphobia
it all exists and so the work
to address injustice wherever it exists
remains the work ahead
my fellow americans it is my great honor
to mention and to say to you what you
already know
we have a president of the united states
in one joe biden who is committed
to this work he is determined
to i will quote from him give hate
no safe harbor and
i'll tell you firsthand i've seen what
you know
his actions match his powerful words
it is my great honor to introduce the
president of the united states
joe biden
thank you
[Applause]
thank you thank you
susan progress is possible
we're moving good afternoon everyone
except for the beginning of my campaign
madam speaker that
the campaign for president throughout
you would call me and tell me keep it up
it was about bringing people together by
uniting the country
we need to reunite we need to unite as
one people
one nation one america and that was the
thing i was most often criticized about
saying how can unite the country
we must unite the country i said it my
kickoff speech in philadelphia
i said it again when i spoke at
gettysburg
and i emphasized it in my inaugural
address
a lot of people press to elected
officials were
somewhat skeptical of that could be done
it's just beginning but i'm confident we
can do this and so much more
and i believe with every fiber in my
being
that there are simple core values and
beliefs that should bring us together
america as americans
one of them is standing together against
hate
against racism the ugly poison that has
long haunted and plagued our nation
today i can say that because of all of
you many of you sitting right in front
of me
you've taken that first step this
important step
i'd like to thank the congress and the
members who are here today democrats and
republicans
who came together to get the covet 19
hate crimes act
on my desk well on a desk i'm about to
sign
but i want to thank the majority leader
schumer and i want to thank speaker
pelosi for your leadership
i also want to thank our
the leader from the state of kentucky
for letting it go forward
it's important it's important most of
all
amazing senator
i called you maisy i apologize man
i called chuck chuck anyway yeah
senator hirano senator tammy duckworth
who
helped deliver this 94-1 vote
when you get involved tammy you don't
screw around you just did it
94-1 state representative grace mann
judy chu who helped deliver a 600
and i should be 364 to 62 vote in the
house of representatives
that's incredible i also want to thank
as i said
republican members in congress for their
leadership including senator moran
and senator collins i also want to thank
the as i said to tell and to all
to all of the folks all the people here
today
who are involved and those of you
whether you're in the congress or not
supporting this effort i say thank you
thank you thank you we got a lot more to
do
we simply haven't seen this kind of
bipartisanship for much too
long in washington you're showing our
that our democracy can work and deliver
for the american people
just days after the mass shooting in
atlanta
uh area the vice president harris and i
we went down to atlanta to meet with
asian americans
and the community across georgia it was
a raw
and emotional visit we had we heard
about their pain their fear
anger and all that existed in the
community and the feelings were
about those feelings that they felt
invisible
not seen we heard how too many asian
americans have been
waking up each morning this past year
genuinely
genuinely fearing for their safety just
opening the door and walking down the
street
and a safety for the loved ones the moms
and dads
when they let their kids out the door to
go to school
or attacked blamed
scapegoated harassed during this
pandemic
living in fear for their lives as i said
just walking down the street
grandparents afraid to leave their homes
even to get vaccinated
for fear being attacked small business
owners targeted and gunned down
students worried about two things covet
19
and being bullied documented incidents
of hate against asian americans has seen
a shocking spike as the vice president
has outlined at the front of
her comments let alone let alone the
ones that have never been reported
gut-wrenching attacks on some of the
most vulnerable people in our nation the
elderly low-wage workers women
brutally attacked simply by walking
outside or waiting for a bus
asian american women suffered twice as
many incidents harassment
and violence as asian-american man
the conversation we had in atlanta is
one we're hearing all across the country
that all of this hate hides in plain
sight
it hides in plain sight and too often
it is met with silence silenced by the
media
silenced by our politics and silenced by
our history
for centuries asian americans native
hawaiians pacific
islanders diverse and vibrant
communities have helped build this
nation only to be often stepped over
forgotten or ignored
you know lived here for generations
was still considered by some the other
the other it's wrong
it's simply to use the phrase it's
simply unamerican
my message to all of those you are
hurting is we see
and the congress has said we see you
and we are committed to stop the hatred
and the bias
my first week in office i signed a
presidential memorandum
directing federal agencies all of them
to combat the resurgence of xenophobia
not just one
every agency attorney general garland
deputy attorney general lisa monaco
associate attorney general gupta
are all here today the department of
justice
is strengthening his partnership with
the community to prevent these crimes
in addition to its other work to take on
violent extremism
and domestic terrorism and with the new
law
this new law the department of justice
and our entire administration is going
to step
up right now this is a critical problem
of hate crimes being
under-reported it stems from two
challenges
first there's lack of resources and
training for state and local law
enforcement to accurately identify and
report
hate crimes to the fbi secondly
for more people in communities of color
there are language and cultural barriers
in how to communicate
what's happening to them this law is
going to make a difference for example
the department of justice will issue
clear guidance for state
city and tribal and law enforcement
agencies on how to establish
online reporting of hate crimes it will
work with the department of health and
human services
to raise public awareness of covet 19
hate crimes that occurred
during the pandemic we'll also be a
devoted official
at the department of justice whose sole
job
is to expedite the review of hate crime
reports
and thanks to two families here today
we'll all help state
and local governments ensure hate crime
information is more accessible to the
public
the family of heather heyer a civil
rights activist whose life was taken
standing up to
nazis marching from the shadows of
vengeance in charlottesville
the family of collide jabara a proud
son of a family who's immigrated from
lebanon
in search of new beginnings with gunned
down in front of their home
here in america united states of america
by a neighbor fueled by hate
cleed and heather were murdered on the
same day
one year apart instead of sharing the
dreams they had for their children
both families share profound grief and
they've shown incredible courage
to turn their pain into purpose i hope
you'll not be offended but ask both
families to please stand
[Applause]
because i know it's hard
no matter how celebratory it is it's a
loss to being changed
when you have to show up at something
memorializing your family
it's like you got the news 10 seconds
ago
it's the hardest thing to do
i know from experience it takes enormous
courage
but i hope i hope that every day has
passed
a memory showing daughter
brings a smile to your lips before it
brings a tear to your eye
because i promise you a lot of people
understand who've gone through similar
things
it's hard so i really mean when i say
thank you
thank you for being here it takes a lot
of courage
because of you the amendment named in
honor of khalid and heather
is now law to make sure that hate crimes
are more accurately counted and reported
and hopefully leading to a continued
focus on ending
these crimes it will provide resources
to create specialized hate crimes units
that will also help states create
hotlines for hate crimes at state and
local levels
that will be accessible for people with
limited english proficiency
and provides resources for training for
state and local law enforcement
to identify investigate and report these
heinous crimes
but of all the good that the law can do
we have to change our hearts we have to
change the hearts of the american people
can i mean this from the bottom of my
heart hate can be given no
safe harbor in america i mean it
no safe harbor can't be dismissed
like well that's just what happens
my sister valerie and i talk about it
all the time
you got to speak up speak up and speak
out
it's on all of us all of us together
to make it stop my message is
to all those who think this doesn't
matter to them or this is not a problem
look around look in the mirror
look in the eyes of your children
every one of us are lessened
every one of us are lessened we're all
hurt
by this hate as a way of seeping sort of
through the cracks
in the communities and children who in
fact
wouldn't have crossed their mind
words have consequences the senator
knows
he preaches it he understands it
consequences but silence
is complicity silence is
complicity and we cannot be complicit
we have to speak out we have to act
that's what you've done
and i can't thank you enough
i'm proud today i'm proud today
of the united states i'm proud today
of our political system the united
states congress i'm proud today
that democrats and republicans have
stood up together
to say something
let me close with this
grief as we all know is universal
but so is hope so is love
sounds corny but it really is it really
is
and hope and love can be contagious
we're the united states of america
we're good and decent people
we're unique among all nations and that
we are uniquely a product
of a document not an ethnicity
not a religion not a geography
of a document and think about this i'm
being liberal
uniquely a product but document that
says we hold these truths to be
self-evident
that all men and women are created equal
endowed by their creator with certain
inalienable rights
including life liberty and the pursuit
of happiness
every time we're silent
every time we let hate flourish
we make a lie of who we are as a
i mean it literally
we cannot let the very foundation
of this country continue to be eaten
away
like it has been in other moments in our
history and happening again
i looked at this law that you all passed
as maybe the first
break first significant break
in a moment in our history it has to be
turned around
not democrat reveal has to be turned
around
as a consequence we should do what is
required
by the obligations of this democracy
by our faith in god and our faith in
each other
to do justice love mercy
to walk humbly and as fellow human
beings and fellow americans
remember we're unique in all history as
a nation
this is the united states of america for
god's sake
and god bless you all particularly those
who push this through
and continue to push it and i'm going to
sign this bill
which is a great honor
i don't know who's calling but tell them
we're busy
i was going to say unless it was my
sister but she's here
so i'd like to invite to the stage
senator hirano senator duckworth
congresswoman grace may congresswoman
judy chu
congresswoman don beyer senator richard
blumenthal
and senator moran but i don't think he
can be here today
actually you should have you i should
put the table down the middle of all of
you
and sign it down there thank you thank
you
[Music]
all right
[Laughter]
okay
oh i'm sorry
[Applause]
[Music]
all right
[Applause]
thank you guys
[Music]
oh
you